hey what is up my name is a journal
welcome to episode 59 of game
programming so today it's going to be
one of those episodes that really
probably isn't that interesting but it
just needs to be done and I actually
asked you guys last episode if you
wanted to see all the graphical aspects
of the development of this game you guys
said yeah like literally everyone I
don't think there was a single no in
there so I guess I'm going to have to
show you guys every aspect of this
game's development so you know we've got
the same thing that we had last time but
what we're basically going to do today
all we're going to do we're going to do
today is actually just finish the tiles
so we have all these tiles here and we
actually made this new tile called the
spawn grass tile right and if we go back
into tile here we can instantiate we can
basically define it by typing public
static tile and that was the spawn what
was it called ice plant get our supply
tile I don't think this spawn grass
style so we'll call it um small grass
tile something okay and I'll set it
equal to new spawn grass tile and the
sprite that we'll use is a sprite dot
and I think it is a perfect spawn yes I
did spawn grass and that's it all right
simple as that
and we basically need to do the whole
the same thing for all the other tiles
that we had so if we actually go to the
sprite class you can see that we also
had a hedge water wool one wool to and
floor all right so if I just tap it over
so those are there's two windows I'll
try and make the camera show both but um
I don't think I will just because of the
it just feels too zoomed out if I do it
that way but um I'm literally going to
copy and paste this stuff here so we've
got frost now in hedge and I guess we
don't need tile to be honest just
because I'm well of it's obviously a
tile so no point in that eh
rule one rule two and a floor as well so
let me first of all copy this and I'll
read the floor all right
that's it so I want to do a sprite and
over here all I'm going to do is hit up
spawn that yeah that's going to be grass
obviously it's going to be hedge and
it's going to be water it's going to be
wool one three wall two and that's going
to be floor and now now what we need to
do is actually change this bone graft on
to the appropriate one so for hedge we
could have a spawn hedge tile for water
we can have a spawn water water tile for
wall we can have a sport football once
all right we have this born wall file
but the thing is guys this is the other
thing it's some things are the same
right
some of the words these like these walls
that we've got going on here these stone
walls like that technically you know
they're the same right they look
different the sprites are different but
they're the same as in they have these
same properties okay in fact a lot of
these tiles have the same properties but
um you know we still want to divide it
just because you know wood might react
differently to how a head does the hedge
might be more upright and could be
destroy you know that a hedge could be
breakable whereas you know a grass tile
wouldn't be and so I like to just mix it
up I like to um I like to keep
everything organized just in case
because I really like my materials to be
you know defined separately but if it's
something like a wall and it literally
just to wall textures and they're
they're only different for esthetical
purposes then we can just go ahead and
say spawn wall tile for both of them and
simply use different sprites all right
and obviously different tile names but
otherwise it's the same right
okay so spawn spawn on the school floor
will be um our spawn floor tile
all right awesome so now we have to go
ahead and create each of these classes
so we'll here this little thing and
we're going to create a class and it
will automatically fill up pretty much
everything for us we want to keep them
in tile except we want to put it on the
spawn level which is the folder that we
created so hit finish and as an error
that occurred assertion failed don't
worry too much about that that is not
really important so this is all good
let's go back to tile and we'll actually
have to just do the same for all the
other ones so again we'll put into spawn
level spawn on the school level and then
we'll you know add the constructor as we
do let's get rid of this go back to tile
so this bought wall tile again that's
just one tile for both of those things
and we'll put it on the spawn level add
back constructor in and that's pretty
much it
one more to go that's the floor tile so
we'll create a class for that level
underscore spawn so it's one below spawn
on the school level and we will in will
add the constructor from our superclass
that's it okay awesome so let's save
that and hopefully we won't get any
errors awesome no errors okay so what we
need to do now the other thing we need
to actually do is we just go to a normal
grass tile you see it's got a random
method so let's grab that random method
and we'll just quickly copy and paste it
into every one of these so just like
that make sure you save after it as well
that's pronounced [ __ ] I think do we do
all of them yeah we did awesome
so I'm just going to right click close
all just because I like to be organizing
it feels really cluttered right now I'll
open tile back up okay
so now that we've got all these
different things we can also go through
I guess another time and be like alright
hedge do we want hedges to be in a
possible you know do we want them to be
solid so public bullying solid we can
just return false if we don't want it to
be solid all right because remember that
overrides the original solid thing so I
returned true for if it is solid so arm
you know hedges we don't want to pass
through hedges maybe they'll be
breakable
you know walls won't be but hedges you
can like or without you sword and cut it
down on something so I'll make that you
know it'll be it'll be solid but that's
like that's for example why I am you
know we might even put like in the
future like a public bullying called
breakable and this one would you know
return true alright so I'll just I'll
leave this in here because it doesn't do
any harm but um you know a system like
that might be in place in the future
for those kind of tiles so that's like
another reason I guess why I actually
split up all these tiles into different
subclasses instead of just having like a
tile and being like alright well this
this is going to be breakable tile and
there's going to be unbreakable tile and
then I'll just have different names for
them but they'll still refer to the same
class now I don't like to do that that's
just not how I roll
so again what else is in breakable wall
tile let's copy and paste solid for wall
tile cuz a wall is solid indeed and well
yeah that's about it so that is how we
organize each one of those tiles next
time tomorrow I'm going to take a look
at actually creating levels based on
this level so in other words we will
create a spawn level next time and we'll
see all these tiles and actions in
actions in action actions multiple there
will be multiple actions with level I'm
sure but um yeah that's what what that's
what we're going to do next time I want
to take a look at actually creating the
spawn level and
in action so you guys next time if you'd
like the video please hit that like
button and I'll see you guys tomorrow
let guys
you